[Music]
Charles Bukowski was a twentieth-century
American writer and poet known for his
unfiltered potent and often crude takes
on life
Bukowski was born in Germany in 1920 and
then emigrated with his family to
America in 1923
Bukowski had a horrible childhood beaten
regularly by his father starting at age
six as an immigrant from Germany
Bukowski was ridiculed by other kids for
his accent and clothing ostracized as an
outcast throughout his schooling into
his teenage years
Bukowski developed a condition that
covered his face with extreme acne and
acne related blemishes further
intensifying his self-consciousness and
isolation the circumstances of abuse and
loneliness imposed on Bukowski as a
young child and adolescent laid the
groundwork for his perspective on life
and his desire to express himself as a
writer in an interview much later in his
life Bukowski said that his father was a
great literary teacher because he taught
him the meaning of pain
more specifically pain without reason
when you get the [ __ ] kicked out of you
long enough
you will have a tendency to say what you
really mean I said Bukowski in his 20s
after two years at college
Bukowski would quit school and make his
first real attempt to becoming a
professional writer bouncing around the
United States doing short-term
blue-collar jobs while writing hundreds
of short stories however out of the
hundreds of stories only a couple during
this time would go on to get published
and the ones that did found essentially
no success after a couple years Bukowski
basically stopped writing altogether
disappointed by the publishing process
and his apparent inability to write well
enough to be successful Bukowski would
go on to work various blue-collar jobs
for several years thereafter then in
1955 at 35 years old after about ten
years of not writing Bukowski nearly
died from a serious bleeding ulcer he
survived however and then soon after as
fate would have it
Bukowski quit his job which was at the
post office at the time and began
writing again a couple more years went
by and Bukowski would publish several
pieces during this time but still
nothing was providing much success and
he was forced to return to the post
office of which he had originally quit
countered to the original time though
this time because he continued writing
while at the post office before his
shift he would use whatever time he had
to write because he would continue in
this for many years getting a collection
of pieces published here and there in
under
magazines all with very little success
with no real sight of success or money
or fame or even just creating a living
from writing because he continued
writing nearly every day before work for
years of course we know how Bukowski
story ended he's being spoken about
right now as a writer a renowned
successful and important enough one to
be spoken about with significance
decades after his passing to be
considered one of the Great's of all
time Bukowski however didn't end up
becoming traditionally or publicly
successful until he was into his 50s
many more years into the second stint of
working at the post office only after a
long continued attempt at writing
typical Skees work finally become
noticed and appreciated by an audience
and only after a deal with a publisher
who agreed to fund Bukowski's work did
Bukowski begin to make any sort of
living from it at 50 years old on the
tail end of the traditional career
timeline
Bukowski got his first real shot and
took it after it would seem like too
many that it was over it began and he
would soon become increasingly
successful and famous in the literary
world and culture at large not long
after it took Bukowski years and years
of writing and toiling and trying to
finally have circumstances work out in
his favor so he could gain traction and
find success as a writer to get what he
wanted since he was a teenager and
fulfill what he believed his life was
for in this it is at least initially
perplexing that his gravestone reads
right now don't try a message that seems
rather grim especially for a gravestone
as well as counterintuitive to a story
how could a man who became successful in
fulfilling his idea of himself a man who
although it took a while found immense
respect and recognition for his craft
all because of his relentless trying how
could this man leave the words don't try
as his final offering arguably perhaps
this is where the most important idea
can be found not only in Bukowski's work
but in Bukowski's life in a letter to
William Packard a publisher friend and
fellow writer
Bukowski wrote to many writers write for
the wrong reasons
they want to get famous or they want to
get rich or they want to get laid by the
girls with the blue bells in their hair
when everything works best it's not
because you chose writing but because
writing chose you it's when you're mad
with it when it's stuffed in your ears
nostrils under your fingernails it's
when there's no hope but that
in this letter info Kowski is referring
to aspiring writers but he's arguably
referring to something much larger the
notion of purpose and success and
creative endeavors in general when you
were very young and someone asked you
for the first time what your favorite
color was and you decided that it was
blue or red or whatever else perhaps it
felt like a choice but it wasn't really
no one chooses how colors make them feel
and why some seem to paint under the
brain with better feelings than others
we can describe the reasons why we like
the colors we like but we can't choose
why we do the color sort of chooses us
in a relatively low stakes situation
like our favorite color it's easy to
just realize which one feels best and
declare without trying how one defines
their purpose and carries out the bulk
of their life however is not so easy nor
so low stakes making it inevitably more
complicated convoluted and challenging
although perhaps it is at its core
somewhat the same as knowing your
favorite color and the same letter to
Packard Bukowski went on to say we work
too hard we try too hard
don't try don't work it's they're
looking right at us
taking the kick out of the closed room
in this Bukowski alludes to the idea
that if you have to try to try if you
have to try to care about something or
have to try to want something perhaps
you don't care about it and perhaps you
don't want it perhaps it isn't your
favorite color throughout his life
Bukowski constantly returned to writing
never reducing or modifying his voice
for the sake of something else
never letting the rejection or the
suffering throughout the process
ultimately take writing away from him
it's not that Bukowski didn't try it's
that he didn't try to be something that
he wasn't he tried to be a writer but he
didn't try to want to be a writer nor
did he try to write how he wanted to
write he just did it and kept on doing
it at least creatively we seem to often
perform at our best when we are
ourselves natural and honest attending
to who we really are and what we really
want to say or do without the addition
of ulterior motives without forcing it
or overthinking too much and perhaps
this is in part for Bukowski meant
truthfully no one other than Bukowski
can say or know exactly what Bukowski
ever really thought or meant in anything
and none of this is to suggest that
something is hard and complicated as
purpose and passion and desire and
success as easy or prescribed 'el
because it isn't it's all is unclear and
complicated as the very brain that
contrives the whole system
and it's not as if writing or filmmaking
or painting or making music or business
or whatever else must come easy to the
writer or filmmaker or painter or
musician etc and order for it to be the
right thing or for them to be great at
it but it is likely however that at the
pain and endurance of working through
the process does not feel worth it and
you are not compelled to do it even in
the face of rejection or hardship or
sacrifice then perhaps it is here where
Bukowski might say don't try but if it
does if the thought of not doing the
thing hurts more than the thought of
potentially suffering through the
process if the thought of a life without
it or never having tried it at all
terrifies you if it comes to you threw
you out of you almost as if you're not
trying
perhaps Bukowski might say here try and
if you're going to try go all the way
Charles Bukowski
[Music]
thanks so much for watching if you're
interested in having access to scripts
audio files and other exclusive pursuit
of wonder offerings you can find them
over on the pursuit of wonder patreon
page all patreon contributions help
sustain the channel and are sincerely
appreciated you can find the patreon
page by clicking on the link in the
description or the icon on the screen
thanks again for watching and see you
next video
[Music]